I wanted to focus focus on an element
it's a I haven't done much of this to my
regret there's only so much time in the
lectures to do is I like to think of
myself I was called this actually in the
Pacific Northwest a structuralist who's
a structuralist what is that well we
understand there five elements in chess
space material time also called
development pawn structure King position
so I really really loved pawn structure
and talking about pawn structure for a
moment and I think a very very important
strategic idea in chess is the so called
minority attack are you all familiar
with minority attack okay some of you
are some of you aren't let me explain
what it is all about so in the Classical
School of chess and let me just say when
I think in terms of the classical school
of chess I'm thinking in terms of Morphy
1850 to say the end of the war world war
ii period 1950 so from that hundred
years that's really the classical school
of chess and it was really kappa blanka
who really focused our attention upon
pawn structure he'd like to talk in
terms of the following he would like to
say that
in this position white has to pawn
islands this group and this group and
black has to pawn islands so forth and
so on we're just going to get a position
here for a second oops Knight c3 Knight
f6 Knight f3 Bishop e7 takes tags here
and so we have the so called
ISIL on e or the isolated pawn the pawn
on d4 is considered isolated because it
can't be protected by a fellow pawn the
e2 pawn to C 2 is is missing and thus
you have the ISIL on e pawn and the
isolated pawn position comes from a
whole plethora of openings from efore
d4c 4 you get isolated pawn positions so
kappa blanka came up with this concept
that white now has three pawn islands
this is its own island these three guys
are - this is a 3rd pawn island black
has to pawn islands and kappa blanka
very simply explained that the player
who has the most pawn islands stands
worse in the ending and then he would go
on and demonstrate his meaning at one
moment in the classical era d4 or queen
pawn opening was at least in various
moments as popular as efore and the only
way to play against one
d4 was to play d5 this was the theory of
the time and that after the move c4 e6
Knight c3 knight c6 was played this move
was considered a blunder a mistake C
takes d5 if he takes d5 Bishop g5 c6
doesn't matter
III doesn't matter Bishop e7 Knight f3
we're just getting into a queen's gambit
declined position Bishop d3 rook e8
black was at least equal yeah black was
at least equal and the classical school
of chess preferred to play black why
because according to the classical
school of chess here we have to pawn
islands this guy is one paw an island
this guy's a second Black has this group
of pawns black has this group upon so
from the pawn island perspective it was
even but the idea was that the classical
school of chess said you only can play
where you have an advantage you don't
play in that area of the board where you
have it where you don't have an
advantage and in the area of the board
that White has the advantage he has a
king side majority black has a queen
side majority in the classical school of
chess the Queen side majority was
considered stronger than the King side
majority why because if you ever got
into a King and pawn endgame the Queen
side majority which is distance to your
King was more dangerous than the King
side majority secondly in this position
let us just say I just want to put a
position on the board castles 94 I just
want to put this position on the board
the idea was from for blacks perspective
he has the central outpost efore black
wants to play moves like Bishop f5 92
and what black does is repress whites
majority on the kingside in this
position once again was considered by
the classical chess players favorable
for black we go back for a moment and we
get a different suddenly a revolution
took place with the so called minority
attack this was not something that had
been seen prior and the idea was just
I'm just putting this on the board not
that Bishop takes f6 is a good move as
we know it today but just to exemplify
this was what the minority attack is all
about even though you have D for B for a
to pawn your idea is that you're going
to attack blacks majority you're going
to play b4 b5 try to create a weakness
on the c6
square that you can exploit so the
minority attack really started to
revolutionize opening theory because up
to a moment nobody had played the
majority attack and I love this line
that bent Larsen gave me so bent Larsen
and we all know bent Larsen great
players from the 60s 70s 80s a top top
top player in the world candidate master
and all of this other good stuff so the
point was the Soviet Union challenged
the rest of the world they were going to
put up a squad of 12 players the rest of
the world were going to put up a squad
of 12 players and the question became
who should play board wan for the rest
of the world should it be Bobby Fischer
or bent Larsen
well Bobby Fischer said bent Larsen that
answered that Bobby Fischer stepped
aside for bent Larsen then was very very
good a year to you later Bobby Fischer
won 6-0 against Matt Larsen though
that's another story
it began des dates the bent was sharing
the year this story that he had come
across an openings book in Danish Danish
openings book and he was so happy it was
published in 1920 and the author
explained that you know with the movie
for was White's best and the author was
explaining how to beat each and every
system that black could possibly play
including the caro-kann and the author
explained c6 question mark bad move d4
d5 eat aches d5 exclamation mark C takes
d5 c3 white achieves a Queens gambit
declined reverse and stands better just
full stop because no matter what white
black does let's say black plays Knight
c6 Knight f3 Bishop g4 Bishop d3 Knight
f6 this is absolutely looking like a
Queens gambit declined in Reverse as the
author explains this pawn on c3 after
the move rook c8 there's no op
operations that black can do but with
this rook on e 1 there's an enormous
number of operations that white can do
which involve moves like Knight e5 so
just just throwing out a 4-inch
let's say black plays Bishop d6 let's
say white plays Bishop g5 castles Knight
here Bishop here so we're going to throw
up this move Queen b3 let's sell out
rook b8 Knight here Bishop here and we
get these kinds of situations where this
rook on e 1 can oftentimes play a role
with a sacrifice on g6 so let's just
play a move so we can see what I'm
talking about
takes takes Knight here and what can we
play for black that's really stupid
so that it Allah allows us to do what we
want to do mmm Queen a5 that's pretty
stupid that ranks right up there okay
let's go with Queen a fight because
that's really good
and we get a position like this and so
the idea is let's say but let's let's
just put another move another stupid
move yeah we get this type of well here
Queen c7 actually is with the tempo and
we get this type of his sacrifice three
pawns for a piece and so forth and so on
so the idea was that we without a
minority attack when the minority attack
was unknown this particular structure
was considered extremely good for white
or the mirror reverse right so let's say
today a modern approach for white would
be Bishop d3 knight c6 C 3 and kappa
blanka had a number of games that went
like this Queen B 3 knight c6 here here
here yeah here here here this type of
thing if I got this right have I got
this move order right
yeah I think we have something like this
and so eventually but I'm doing it in
the wrong move order so forgive me for a
moment I'm trying to get to a position
that I want let's just say here here
castles here yeah you can do it oh yeah
here here here that's so now we get to a
position where everybody is happy right
White has his let's take that last move
back because it's too good
we have yeah say rook e1 so this would
be a classical position that the school
of chess from 1850 to 1950 just rated
very highly for white that white has
ideas like Knight e5 rookie three rook
e1 and you just use this outpost e5 this
pawn majority stay silent and white is
doing great
like strategically winning and then came
this idea of the minority attack with b7
b 5 let's just say 95 Queen here and
suddenly this pawn move b4 is very
disruptive white doesn't get all the
time that he wants to play rook e3 and
rook e1 and her cage 3 and Knight g4 or
Bishop g5 so the hon minority is a very
important concept that really altered a
a lot of opening theory and I recall a
game that I was playing with Michael
tall I was white in this game with
Michael tall it was an important game
bla bla bla
and I went into this game thinking very
very specifically is how the hell do I
put this guy in a straitjacket you know
I want a handcuff and I want to arrest
it
no tactics I want to play the most
boring game I possibly could and put him
to sleep if I could and that game was D
for Michael tall was black I was white
and the first thing I wanted to do was
trade off a pair of mine of pieces
because I was figuring the less fire
wood that he had the less fire he could
bring to the table so I played the white
side of the classical names o Queen c2
he played here d5 which was a very
popular move at the time C takes D Phi
he takes d5 Bishop g5 he played h6 and I
took off a pair I took off two pairs of
pieces here thanks to the fact that I
have Knight takes d5 he's essentially
obliged to capture capture castles III
now I remember at the time thinking to
myself now how the hell is Michael tall
going to generate a vicious attack after
I've just taken off four minor pieces
and of course I have this idea like hey
I'm gonna play Queen take c7 if you're
not careful well Misha went into a deep
think
and of course I by the time you know
everybody and his brother would play c7
c6 here without thinking but as tall
spent more and more and more time I knew
that he you know he was a human
calculator he was calculating force
lines lines after line after line after
line and eventually he played the the
move Bishop f5 and there was no way in
heaven I was capturing his pawn on c7
have to be just menu to half an hour
figuring out you know Queen take c7 rook
c8 Creek takes b7 knight c6 you know and
you know ideas of rook c2 and rook b8
and the rest of it
I went night here he went rook c8 so it
was really kind of funny I wanted to
play a minority attack so that I could
restrain his pawns and he was playing to
try to make the advance
c7 c5 if I recall correctly the game
went Knight g3 Bishop e6 b4 a5 Bishop d3
aibee aibee rook takes a 1 queen takes a
one-night c6
B 597 castles c5 and he had achieved for
me what I had wanted I had wanted to
make a minority attack and the whole
goal in a minority attack is to leave
your opponent with a pawn on c6 and
tall's aggressive you know his natural
inclination was to be very aggressive
his aggressive play in fact had
accelerated my play and he had
transformed my position into a sterling
advantage an advantage I actually won in
this game I think I played some move I
believe like Queen a seven followed by
rook C 192 Knight f4 and one okay so
that was one of the things that really
made a big impression on me is that when
black starts to play very actively on
the side of the board where white is
making a minority attack quite often it
rebounds you're simply helping your
opponent that was y way back here at
this point tall should have been more
subdued he should have just played c7 c6
have been prepared to meet Bishop d3
with Bishop f5 if I had played night of
397 castles and rook e8 and I would have
I would have thought that a position
like this is pretty even okay and this
whole idea of this fifth element that is
very often missed in chess or not
studied often enough is the pawn
structure pawn structures tell us what
our what's going on in this position if
I said okay from a structuralist point
of view the natural outpost for the
night if I had in another night I'd be
trying to put a knight on c5 as well as
a knight on e5 if I was black d square C
for an e4 make natural outpost to me I
would be trying to stick another night
on d6 so that I could have an outlook to
both squares c4 an e4 obviously if I
have a dark squared bishop
well I want it outside of the pawn
structure I would want it on this
diagonal so would black and black had a
dark squared bishop he'd wanted on this
diagonal both players have put the
bishops there light squared bishop Zahn
best diagonals the b1 h7 diagonal blacks
rook belongs on e8 White's rooks are
uncertain it's not clear to me if this
rook belongs here and this rook belongs
here but one thing's for sure is I'm
angling for a 4 and B 5 I'm trying to
create a weakness on c6 and this is what
the minority attack is all about and
when the minority attack became and came
into vogue it really rewrote a lot of
opening theory as I explained about the
1920 Danish bride book about chess
openings also one of the things that you
absolutely absolutely have to understand
is an eye Salani position the eye Salani
position because it can come from so
many variations so I'll just put on for
example the lap in Sicilian c5 if I play
c3 you play d5 takes Queen takes d4
Knight f6 Knight f3 let's just say e 6
for a moment isolated queen pawn
isolated queen pawn position
caro-kann isolated queen pawn is
automatic and a lot of Cara cons you
have the pan off bad viniq attack which
for years and years was considered the
most dangerous line of play for black
boots in a variation and we have this
position today Bishop before I should
say is probably the most popular move in
this position but at the time Bishop e7
once again we have a isolated queen pawn
that the Queens gambit declined or
tarush variation oops excuse me let's go
away d4 d5 c4 e6 Knight c3 c5 ok the the
Taira CDE D Knight f3 nuts that's not
the best motive the best move is knight
c6 after 96 the great Akiba Rubinstein
introduced the idea of g3 and then
Knight f6 Bishop g7 Bishop e7 castles
castles takes takes isolate a queen pawn
isolated queen pawn so the first things
I can tell you about the isolated queen
pawn and his properties go like this you
get into an ending you're in bad shape
if you have the isolated queen pawn
Kappa Blanco was right the guy who has
the more pawn islands in the endgame is
it a disadvantage all other things being
equal you hold the isolated queen pawn
you don't want an ending you don't
voluntarily trade pieces you try to
force your opponent to compromise and
trade you make you you avoid unnecessary
trades the player who's playing with the
isolated queen pawn is trying to keep as
many pieces on the board
conversely you're trying to take as many
pieces
off the board so in this position I is
white and numerous others before me have
played as follows and said okay hey
isn't this great
I've got I've got pieces off the board
but in this case black has actually made
something that's rather unusual the
isolated Queen pond instead of being up
this square is actually here in this
position strangely enough this one
advance of the pawn actually makes a
huge huge difference in this position
with the pawn here this Bishop is
actually much more active than with the
pawn here with the pawn on d4 black's
ideas to play Bishop f5 rook d8 rook e8
put his Bishop on e4 and neutralize this
bishop so white players have very often
come to this position and reached a dead
end not able to put enough pressure on
black a favorite line of play of
Anderson at one time had been to take
Queen takes f6 Knight here Queen back
Knight here
so what all Anderson's effort here was
all about is he was trying to prove that
this Bishop on c5 wasn't as good as a
knight so this is a battle of Bishop
versus Knight so after for example in
this position after rook e8 Knight rook
c1 the question was where should black
put his bishop in the good old days they
thought well the bishop you know having
the two bishop is pretty important they
would put their bishop back on f8 and
all Anderson's games which are really
really classic
it would make black suffer I believe it
was Grandmaster Marie Chandler from New
Zealand who showed that the best move
for black was to put the bishop on b6
and the idea in this case was what black
was trying to achieve was after Knight
takes Queen takes to put pressure
against the B to pawn as well as the E
to con Murray's idea was that in case of
Knight c4 let's say Bishop here let's
say rook here so we get a position like
this what Murray's idea was that if you
take this Bishop after this recapture
the rook is very well placed on a 8
again I can't emphasize enough that as
you get better and better and better in
chess you'll start to understand that
pawn structures are crucial for your
plans it really really brings it home
when you study isolated pawns minority
attacks majority attacks you guys have
all heard the expression of pawn storm
right so what exactly is a pawn storm a
pawn storm is the idea that on a
particular flank I'm trying to advance
my pawns the most clear demonstration of
a pawn storm can be seen for example in
the English attack --tags --tags
Knight c3 Knight here a six Bishop e3 e6
here the shifty 7 Queen d2 Queen c7 g4
castles h4 so this is really what a pawn
storm is all about on a particular flank
you're trying to advance especially
against a king let's say just for
argument's sake b5 cast
before 92 and black is trying to well
probably black actually has to play rook
b8 roof ta let's say Knight g3 variation
in 93 and black is trying to return the
favor
over on the King on the Queen side Kings
on opposite flanks everybody makes a
pawn storm against the opponent's king
very very very clear if you don't if you
don't understand the concept of a pawn
storm well you're in real trouble
whenever you've castled on opposite
flanks because you can be pretty sure
your opponent starts attacking your king
and you don't don't start attacking his
king you're the underdog I was doing a
book oh well actually series of books
tactics and combinations I was really
really really trying to understand as
best I could
you know attacks and tactics and things
like this and I asked Gary Kasparov
world's greatest attacking geniuses ever
I said Gary when does an attack begin
pretty basic question think about it
when does an attack begin well Gary came
back very very quickly with his answer
so it was like kind of one of those you
know like caused me provoked me to smile
because I said you've thought about this
yourself he goes yeah
an attack begins when when upon attacks
apiece
you have the attack when your pawn
attacks opponents piece and you know it
sounded like too simplistic like a
simpleton kind of answer actually right
but then when you think about it more
and more like a lot of attacks
preliminarily speaking dart with a pawn
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]